Despite originally refusing to remove controversial
footage included in its horror hit Bird Box,
Netflix has now changed its mind.
The film stars Sandra Bullock as a single
mother living in a post-apocalyptic world
where monsters convince humans to commit suicide
if they catch sight of them.
The Canadian Press confirms that the streamer
will remove from Bird Box footage of the real-life
Lac-Mégantic rail disaster that took place
in 2013.
An unnamed spokesperson for the streaming
giant released an email statement to the outlet
that reads:
"Netflix and the filmmakers of Bird Box have
decided to replace the clip.
We're sorry for any pain caused to the Lac-Mégantic
community."
For those unaware, the initial cut of Bird
Box includes footage from a train crash that
happened on July 6, 2013 in Lac-Mégantic,
Quebec, Canada.
That day, a freight train loaded with crude
oil derailed from the tracks and crashed.
Several of the train's cars exploded and then
caught fire.
The accident left 47 people dead, a large
portion of Lac-Mégantic's downtown buildings
completely destroyed, and most of the city's
downtown area ruined and in need of rebuilding.
Clips of the train tragedy appear within the
first few minutes of Bird Box, during the
scene in which Malorie and her sister Jessica
are watching the news on television.
They see massive explosions and total devastation
wracking a town - footage meant in the film
to indicate that the world is experiencing
a mass epidemic of unexplained violence.
"The eyewitness reports tell of people experiencing
psychotic behavior."
Netflix reportedly obtained the clips from
stock footage company Pond5, where individuals
can purchase images and clips, including those
from newscasts that depict sensitive events.
Another of the streamer's projects, the sci-fi
television show Travelers, also implemented
Lac-Mégantic disaster footage, which Travelers'
production company Peacock Alley Entertainment
stated wasn't intended to "dishonor the tragic
events of 2013."
A spokesperson from Pond5 also issued an apology
for the use of the footage in Travelers:
"We deeply regret that this happened and sincerely
apologize to anyone who was offended, especially
the victims and their families … We are
contacting all customers who have purchased
any related clips to ensure they are aware
of the sensitive nature of this footage.
Additionally, we're proactively re-auditing
content of this nature, while continuing to
improve our guidance for usage."
When Netflix was made aware of the situation
as it relates to Bird Box, however, the streamer
refused to remove the footage at first.
A spokesperson indicated that Netflix would
keep the clip in the movie, and would be,
quote, "looking at ways to do things differently
moving forward."
Many were outraged at Netflix's original decision,
none more than Lac-Mégantic Mayor Julie Morin
and Quebec Culture Minister Nathalie Roy.
Morin wrote that the use of the footage and
subsequent refusal to take it out of Bird
Box after knowing all the facts showed a complete
lack of respect for the people of Lac-Mégantic
and those affected by the 2013 disaster.
She said:
"It's hard enough for our citizens to see
these images when they are used normally and
respectfully on the news.
Just imagine, to have them used as fiction,
as if they were invented."
Roy singled out Netflix CEO Reed Hastings
for criticism, writing that Netflix was exhibiting
a, quote, "lack of compassion, empathy, and
solidarity" in its decision.
She also stated that the Quebec government
found it unbelievable that Netflix wouldn't
remove the clips from Bird Box or think that
it was okay to implement them in the first
place.
"I think it's a huge mistake.”
Now that Netflix has reversed its choice - having
already updated the film as of the making
of this video - Morin is satisfied and willing
to look past the streamer's initial refusal.
She said:
"Yes, there was a delay, but I think in the
end, what's more important for me, is that
we have a solution to this situation we felt
was important to settle."
Morin further noted that the entertainment
industry needs to "reflect on this" and other
situations like this to hopefully create a
new standard for the use of stock footage
in films and television series.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.